Elon hello welcome
are you in Palo Alto I understand
yeah
first well a Global Engineering
headquarters in Palo Alto great well
thank you so much for joining us
um I'm actually going to start somewhere
a little bit differently than I expected
um because I just saw on Twitter on
Twitter
um a little announcement
um I would love to get your your
thoughts on it I see your uh
interviewing Rhonda santis tomorrow
morning
is that right on Twitter spaces I see
yes it's uh I need like the exact time
but oh tomorrow morning your time I
think it would be probably correct okay
um so uh yes I
um
will be interviewing
Ron Santos and he has quite an
announcement to make
um and we'll be we're the first time
that's something like this is happening
on social media and with the real-time
questions and answers uh no not scripted
uh so it's Gonna Be Live and Let Let
let's see what happens
foreign and you've been tweeting some
Tim Scott stuff in the last few days
um what should we be thinking about who
you're backing obviously this interview
tells us something can you give us a
sense of where your thinking is at the
moment
yes I mean I'm not at this time
um planning to endorse any particular
cancer
um but I am interested in uh
you know X slash Twitter being somewhat
of a public town square and uh where
more and more organizations host content
and make announcements on Twitter
um it's the it's the only place on the
internet to really get uh real-time like
down to the minute and second news
and it's uh
yeah so I think it's it's quite
groundbreaking that there'd be
um
a major announcement
of this type on social media
um
and should we expect
um sorry I don't want to go on too long
about this but um in your new role as
interviewer rather than interviewee uh
should we expect
um uh should we expect more of this I
mean if it's the Town Square are you
going to be interviewing other
candidates Democrats what's your what's
your thought of this are people willing
to come are you going to be there to
execute the Town Square across the
Spectrum yes absolutely
um so just as I as I promised when I do
a series of media interviews I did a
range of interviews
um and uh I guess this would be also a
media interview
um so ranging from sort of on the you
know left moderate to what's considered
right
um and I do think it's important that
Twitter be uh have both the reality and
the procession of uh Level Playing Field
of uh
a place where uh all voices are heard
and where uh as the kind of dynamic
interaction that is you don't really see
anywhere else
um I'll meet you today on Twitter for
example
um
uh AOC got into an and Ted Cruz got into
an argument on Twitter which was
um yeah independent of which side do you
agree with
um it's still very entertaining
so what um and I'm sure tomorrow will be
entertaining we're all going to be tuned
into that but um
when you when you approach an interview
like that and and obviously a really
important election like the one that is
coming up you can you just talk a little
bit about what are the key issues that
really matter for you at this pivotal
moment
you can matter for me as an individual
or matter for you as an individual
um in terms of who leads the country but
also you know more broadly than that you
know for the country and for for your
businesses I mean can you give your
sense of of where the real issues lie
here
well I've said publicly that
um my preference and I think would be
the preference of most Americans is
really to have someone fairly normal in
office
I think we'd all be quite uh quite happy
with that actually
um you know I think someone that uh is
representative of the moderate views
that I think most the country holds in
reality
um and um
but but the way things are set up is
that we we do have a system that seems
to push things towards the edges because
of the primaries so in order to win the
primary you've got to win obviously
majority of your parties vote in both
cases that tends to
cause a swing to the left and the right
although I think things are more complex
than simply left and right
during the primaries and then uh and
then let's shift towards the center for
the Journal election
um
as far uh what what I think is yeah so I
would really just like someone you know
fairly normal accessible to be the
president that would be great so if we
go through the if we go through the four
names in the frame at the moment can you
just give a sort of yes no whether
they're normal and sensible
um so um we've got Joe Biden I
I think
you know be careful about these
statements
um
so I uh we'd maybe have to have a few
drinks before I would give you the
answers
I will um I will look forward to that
and I look forward to the uh to the
conversation tomorrow and obviously a
lot more of those to come over the
coming months so um that's great thank
you very much um
so
what I wanted to start with you've just
flown in I think in the last 20 minutes
um you live a pretty hectic lifestyle
um
but you've said that the only true
currency is time
can you give a sense to the people in
this room who are scheduled within an
inch of their lives sort of how you you
what is a day in the life of Elon Musk
what does that look like
well weddings are very long and
complicated as you might imagine yeah
um and um and there's a great there's a
great deal of context switching so
um
doesn't mean my life called like
relating to Doom where it's like fear is
not the mind killer context switching is
uh so switching context is is quite
painful but
um I do generally try to divide
uh companies that's predominantly one
company on one day so today is a Tesla
day for example
um
although I might end up at Twitter late
tonight
um and then tomorrow would be partly a
Tesla day as well
have Twitter and
um
and then Thursday would be sort of a
half SpaceX have Tesla day but these
things are somewhat intertwined so the
time management is extremely difficult
um and this is going to sound pretty
strange but I um I only have one uh
part-time assistant
um how many days a week is that the
part-time
I mean I suppose I suppose how she works
who were technically full-time but as
such I I do most of the scheduling uh
myself
um and the reason I do that is because
it's impossible for someone else to know
what the priorities are
um
so
the and since the most valuable thing I
have is time I schedule it myself
for the most part
so if you come into Tesla today do you
have a series of meetings
set up or do you
um come in with you know something on
your mind and you go in and see people I
mean how structured is this or if you
shop at Twitter
in terms of the people working for you
how do they how do they handle that
um yeah so today I have several hours of
scheduled meetings at Twitter
um so there are a number of of things
that are operated on a weekly Cadence
um and so those meetings are already set
up and then I have supplemental meetings
at the end of the day
um particularly I I I I won't be going
to sleep until probably 2 A.M or
something like that and be working
almost the entire time and if you're
shaking this yourself is AI going to be
helpful over the next few years to help
you
um do this
and you're going to be using technology
to help you manage that
I guess we'll all be using technology
I don't use a lot of AI
myself day-to-day I mean Tesla AI is
actually very Advanced for real world AI
it's the most advanced remote World AI
um by far
um
and in fact if positions were swapped
and it would say up to Microsoft and
open AI to create uh who could create
the best large language model
basically if the tests were swapped
Tesla was given that the task of making
the most competitive large language
model and Microsoft open AI were tasked
with self-driving Tesla would win okay I
don't think people understand the degree
of depict the capability of Tesla's AI
system
so
while I don't use AI a lot personally
Tesla uses a trans mount we'll get on to
that in a second if that's okay but one
final thing in terms of just the
management of what you do with your life
you're running three very big companies
you have very big stakes and you know
ownership control of of two of those at
least
um
what is your succession plan if you
suddenly call and execute what you're
doing both in terms of who runs the
companies but as importantly who votes
those shares in terms of
um you know what happens longer term and
strategically what have you got a plan
for all of those
yeah
um succession is one of the toughest
age-old problems
um you know it's it's a it's plagued
um
you know countries Kings
Prime Ministers and presidents for and
CEOs for you know
since the dawn of History
um there is no obvious solution I I mean
there are particular individuals
identified as that that I've told people
would look if something happens to me
unexpectedly this is who my this is my
recommendation for taking over
so in all cases the board is aware of of
who my recommendation is which they may
choose to it's up to them of course they
they may choose to go a different
direction but I they there is a in in
worst case scenario this is who should
run a company
uh the control question is a much more
it's a much tougher question
um and something that I'm wrestling with
and I'm frankly open to ideas because
it certainly is true that the companies
that I have created and are creating
um collectively possess uh immense
capability and so the stewardship of
them is incredibly important
um I want to make sure that the
stewardship is ultimately uh
accrues the benefit of humanity that's
the idea is the tolerance of
civilization
um
but they're not that we're always
successful in that but that is
aspirationally our goal
um
so
I I have one one idea which is sort of
partly in place which is to create kind
of a
an a sort of a educational institution
that that would control
um
most of my vote
but this is this is not a case of
um
automatically I I'm definitely not not
of the school of automatically giving my
kids a
you know some share of the companies
even if they are not even if they have
no interest or inclination
you know or ability to to manage the
companies I think that's a mistake
um so but but it's a very hard problem
to solve right so and then who should be
on the board of directors of the
educational institution is also a very
very hard job to solve
um
so I think probably some disaggregation
of control would make sense
I'm really just kind of thinking out
loud creatively here but it sounds like
it's something that you I mean you need
to get planning of who those people are
going to be because as you've said
whether when you look at SpaceX you look
at Tesla you look at Twitter these these
matter to society a lot and having the
right people
to take those votes on the future of
where they go and where money gets spent
is is fairly important
yes absolutely now the goals of the
companies they're the achievement of
those goals varies considerably in
difficulty
um you know the the original goal of
Tesla was to accelerate the Advent of
sustainable energy which actually I
think we've done done that to a
significant degree
um and have actually it's kind of of uh
it's kind of it's kind of a order
industry CEOs too often acknowledge
Tesla's role in accelerating
electric vehicles
um
and um
yeah so so that that I feel has a lot of
momentum
um
they're still solving self-driving which
were you know aspirationally hoping to
do this year uh
and um
and so it has got a long way to go but
but the execution plan is relatively
clear
um
and uh
the next that execution plan will
generate a lot of positive cash flow for
the company so it's like if it's a
fairly obvious thing to do with SpaceX
it's a harder problem because
uh the long-term objective is to make
life multi-planetary with a
self-sustaining City on Mars which is
likely to be very casual or negative uh
at first
a long term let's just say the target
market on Mars is small
you got to think long term yeah you're
also going to have to get on very well
with those you go with I would imagine
uh yes definitely
um
you know sanity will be a prime
requirement for uh and stability for
traveling to Mars you don't want someone
going nuts and opening the airlock in
the middle of the night
um right so
SpaceX is a harder problem because it's
it's
uh much a long-term goal and and with uh
a lot more money less along the way so
gotta make sure that that happens
um
and is that the sort of thing just to
stay on SpaceX and we'll go to Twitter
and tell us in a second but
um is that the sort of thing that you'd
like to lock in to the goals of SpaceX
that Mars Remains the ultimate
um ambition of this come what may is
that is that that important to you
yeah I mean it's to make light
multi-planetary such that
um and the key threshold for
multi-planatory is that if the supply
ships from Earth stop coming for any
reason that a Mars does not die out
that's that's the that's the critical
great filter if you talk about things in
terms of the Fermi Paradox the great
filter is
um Mars being self-sustaining without
any resupply shows from Earth until we
reach that point we're really just a one
planet
civilization with uh
an extension but the point in which the
planets are self-sustaining Oman is
self-sustaining then
even in a worst case scenario of of
Earth civilization either dying with a
bang or a whimper
um then Mars would have a much better
chance of surviving
um so the intent here overall is to
ensure the light of Consciousness which
appears to be just a tiny candle and a
vast Darkness
um I frequently I frequently get asked
have I seen any evidence of aliens and I
I I'm not
um you know apart from the fact that I
didn't at one point have an alien
registration card when I was getting my
uh green green card uh it's an alien
registration
um indeed
possibly a slightly different type of
alien but um so do you think you'll will
you live to see Mars happen
I I hope to love to see the first humans
on Mars
um
but I think it'll take some period of
time beyond that to make my
self-sustaining so it's at least 20
years from the first visit to make my
sustain as my guess and it may be 40 or
50. and that's assuming you really go
for it right so
that's a tough one
um
but like so I think important for
improving the survivability of
civilization
and who's going to pay for that I mean
are your
investors gonna put the money up to do
that are you going to expect government
to fund that where does that money come
from because as you say you can make a
return on starlink you can make a return
on launching satellites for other people
and space tourism but I mean that's a
that's a tougher return Isn't it
yeah I think I think long term uh the
value of it will be incredibly high I
would just it's just beyond the planning
Horizon of most people or most investors
so
um I mean obviously if
um if there's a thriving
um City on Mars and there's a lot of
interplanetary Commerce and SpaceX is
the primary provider of that it would be
immensely valuable
um
so
um but but you know the one thing is
that at the be this self-sustaining
you know Colony um and um
I think we we I think we
uh
generally operate with too much of an
assumption that Civilization is robust
um and nothing could really take it down
uh a sentiment that has been common
throughout history among Empires shortly
before they called it
so and you know I have to say that you
know there's a little bit of late stage
Empire Vibes going on right now
um uh yeah for sure
are you um yeah
um
uh is is AI something that in your view
accelerates the risk of that or
increases the risk of that at that
outcome
I think it does yeah
um I mean we could definitely make a
city of Mars self-sustaining without
without AI or without sort of AGI which
is generally artificial general
intelligence or super intelligence
I have so I think that that is uh it's
not necessary for anything we're doing
um but it is happening and happening
very quickly so uh
there is a risk that uh Advanced AI
um
either eliminates or constrains
Humanities growth
I was more thinking the opposite does it
increase the chance that plant the
planet self input implodes and those
things come true you I mean how
concerned are you about these
developments right now sort of
accelerating your
your bad case scenario here
well uh I mean the development of
artificial digital sort of super
intelligence uh
is very much a double-edged sword so
it's if you have if you have a genie
that can grant you anything
they can also do anything
um that necessarily is
presents a danger and I expect the first
uses of AI to be
or certainly the first government uses
of AI to be weapons technology
so just having
um
more advanced weapons on the battle if
you go back that can react uh faster
than any human could
that's
that's really what AI will be capable of
I mean future Wars between
Advanced countries or at least countries
that have significant drone capability
will be very much the Drone Wars
so I want to get back to AI because this
is this is big stuff and I'd like to to
talk about in more detail but I do want
to come just come back to the present
from a long way in the future
um you've just hired a new CEO uh Linda
yacarino an ad veteran um into Twitter
you usually focus on hiring Engineers
you know Linda is a very different
person can you just quickly tell us
about your courtship how did that go
down
well
um
we had conversations over a number of
months uh just relating to advertising
um and then uh Linda felt that um
it would be very helpful for the
advertisers to see me in person so
invited me down to a conference in Miami
um which was very helpful and met with a
number of advertisers personally to
assure their you know assure them that
that Twitter is a good place to
advertise in a and generally that in
fact that that hate speech is declined
which it has and that the quality of the
system
especially with respect to scammas and
spammas is dramatically better than it
used to be
um we've gotten rid of at this point
well over 90 percent of those the scams
and scams the scams and spam on Twitter
it should be quite rare at this point at
UCS camp
um
so
um we've also rolled out uh sort of so
just to be clear when you say you've got
rid of 90 of the scams is it but is that
the same thing as the Bots or is this
scams in general and Bots is a different
animal here they were typically used
Bots for scan
but you haven't taken the Bots down 90
percent
no I think we we have actually I think
you have okay yeah yeah I think we have
yeah maybe more than 19. now you've said
at least
um is now much much harder to operate a
platform on Twitter and have it uh yield
any any uh advantage
um
so uh dramatic Improvement in Bots
dramatic Improvement and ability to
detect uh sort of trial armies which is
a little different that's where you've
got say oh you know um a hundred people
in a warehouse in a low-wage country
Each of which are sitting at a desk with
100 phones so you've got 10 000 actual
people
and they will then act together to
Brigade a particular subject or make
something seem very popular when it is
not
um and we've been able to defeat almost
all of them we think very few of them
are actually still able to to operate
so quality of the system has gotten a
lot better okay so
um
if you said to Linda that you
are going to keep speaking your mind
whatever the commercial impact of that
and has she agreed to that is she happy
with that you aligned
uh yeah okay
and in her role as CEO
does she have any say over moderation or
is that under you or you do you do that
together
well the general principle is that
um
we were we were here close to the law so
for any given country we will try to
adhere as closer to the low as possible
our law is very between countries and we
can't simply fight the law in in
um
in another country because they will
simply cut us off
um so
the general principle is do whatever we
can to
enable free and open Communications with
between people
um provided they're not like I said
breaking she's aligned on on that
that plan yeah that Focus
um yeah there is an important thing
which is like that that obviously
doesn't mean that say advertisers should
be forced to appear next to any content
so we've also developed adjacency
controls that ensure that if what you're
advertising is um like Disney Disney for
example is a big Advertiser it doesn't
use advertising a children's movie they
you know it won't want the the contents
nearby to be sort of family friendly
that's totally understandable
um so uh so it's it's not like
advertisers have to appear next to
content that they that they don't agree
with and can you um so some people say
you're you can't be a little erratic
with your Tweeting or at least
um tweet a broad range of of content um
does anybody say I don't want to be
adjacent to Elon Musk is that is that
something that's happened on the on the
platform
I've never heard that yet um
but uh
um
and did it did that come up with Linda
at all sort of what you tweet and and
whether that was something that could
affect advertisers did she did she ask
you about that
uh she did it in fact at the conference
that we did in Miami so we speech is
Paramount fine
um I wanted to ask you a little bit
about your vision for Twitter as a as a
community and as a as a conversation
um you've talked about your desire to
maximize unregretted time can you just
could you explain what that means and
how you measure that
uh yeah so
uh previously Twitter was mostly uh
focused on this number called uh they
called mdow monetizable daily active
users
um but the problem is that when you look
closely at that a bunch of those users
um never even went to Twitter they would
go to
um
uh there would see a notification on
their phone about a tweet but they
wouldn't actually click through the site
so but what really matters is uh true
user seconds of screen time
um so that's that's the figure we track
right now and that's based on the the
screen time as reported To Us by uh uh
iOS Android and the browser so
um it would be it would have to be the
time the amount of time the app is in
the foreground
right is the most rigorous way to assess
this
so so when you say unregret it sorry
please keep going exactly so in terms of
undergraded it's
that's a little harder to measure
um
but we can certainly gather it
anecdotally which is to say that if you
spent you know half an hour on Twitter
yesterday what percentage of the
percentage of that time do you regret
um and journaling the feedbackup button
has been very positive uh that they they
find it's the information to be useful
entertaining funny
um so we seem to be heading the right
direction as far as I can tell I'm
certainly open to any critiques from the
room
well let me let me ask you one on that
which is
um you know you recently tweeted about
George Soros you said
um let me get back well let me just get
the words because I'm kind of interested
in what you think about this he wants to
erode the very fabric of civilization
Soros hates Humanity that obviously
generated a huge amount of response on
Twitter on both sides lots of different
viewpoints is that unregrettable time
unregretted time that that debate that
you created does that fit into that
category do you think
well I mean I said like Source reminds
me of Magneto you know uh
well you know you went a little further
than that but again without going into
the Soros tweet itself you know you're
obviously a big figure on Twitter and
you're setting a tone and a name so I'm
just curious as to whether that sort of
debate which which gets triggered is
that does that fit into the definition
that you're trying to create in that New
Town Square
well I mean I think the important thing
is that like look what I say is not uh
is what I'd say
um you know it's sort of a Town Square
I'm not going to mitigate what I say
because that would be inhibiting for
your freedom of speech that doesn't mean
you have to agree with what I say in
order to mean if somebody says the total
opposite that they're that they won't be
supported on Twitter they are
um the point is to have a diversion set
of views and free speech is only
relevant um if it's a speech by a speech
by someone you don't like who says
something you don't like is that allowed
if if so you have free speech otherwise
you do not and for those who would
Advocate censorship I would say it is if
if you succeed in that it's only a
matter of time before the censorship
gets turned on you I agree I mean you
can that's your free speech definition
which you said but I'm just curious as
to on the unregrettable part
what what what what type of conversation
you're trying to achieve and whether
that's something that is acceptable but
maybe not where you want the broader
conversation to go
well I mean I did clarify that you know
some of my concerns about Taurus are
that he's funded um
a very large number of uh small but
influential races around the country
especially with District Attorneys
um and we find that for example the
alien uh and and San Francisco district
attorney races uh
uh with uh chess boarding and um
the guy always I always want to call him
Gaston from Beauty and the Beast driving
um
and and the
the it's basically he's he's
um of course a large number of
the ASP elected who are very easy on
crime and will often fuse refuse to uh
prosecute so you were basically trying
to make a deeper point with that short
yeah
um can I just move on quickly to um
because I don't want to go too far down
that that rabbit hole because that
debate has played out on Twitter a bit
is um
you know are you back near profitability
now
Twitter is not quite there but we we're
we're not like you know when I first
acquisition closed I would say it's
analogous to being teleported into a
plane that's plunging to the ground with
its engines on fire the controls don't
work
um
so it's comforting say the least
um now we have to do some pretty
heavy-handed uh bus Cutting Company
healthy but we're at this point we're
training towards
if we get lucky we might be casual
casual positive next month but it
remains to be seen and is the Staffing
the level you now want it or are you
going to start taking it back up again
from this it's gone from I think 8 000
to about 1500 or something like that is
that crazy correct yeah
um I think there's you know there's um
there's definitely we are going to start
adding people to the company
um and we have started adding some
number of people to the company
um
and um but it's still there's still a
lot of change to have to happen so
but I I think 1500 is probably a
reasonable number
and does this show what you can do
um in a big tech company in terms of
cost reduction I mean when you look
around other big tech companies in
Silicon Valley
um would you say from your experience
that there's room for
much more significant change at those as
well
yeah I think Twitter maybe somewhat of
an outlier in that um
that there were
a lot of people doing things that that
didn't seem to have a lot of value
um and
that's I think that's true probably at
most the Silicon Valley companies
um maybe not to the degree to which it
was a Twitter but uh it's still
yeah
there's a potential for significant Cuts
I think out of the companies without
affecting their productivity in fact
increasing their productivity
um so
you know um
at any given company there are people
who help move things forward and and
people who've sort of tried to slam the
brakes on and Twitter was in a situation
where you'd have a meeting of 10 people
you know and one person with an
accelerator and nine nine with a set of
brakes
um so you didn't go very far right
um
and um
so now now we're going home about
releasing functionality even with a
little bit of risk to side stability as
soon as it's not too serious and I think
this point is probably fair to say we
were introduced more functionality in
the last uh six months than Twitter has
in the last six years and in terms of
outages there were some outages early on
are you are you confident things are
stable now
well outages Are Not Unusual Instagram
recently had an outage for example it
was reported on Twitter ironically
um so uh we've had outages but not not
massive ones and they've generally been
brief and limited in scope okay
um
do you regret buying it you tried to get
out of it or are you now happy you
bought it
well all's well that ends well
has it ended well yet or we still got to
wait and see
um I think we're on the hopefully on the
uh comeback Arc okay
so I mean one of the things you have
talked about you bought it for 44
billion you've talked about it one day
being worth 250 I think in internal
meetings can you just talk about how you
get there what is the what is the bigger
Vision I mean you want to bring back
advertisers now and are they coming back
by the way
yeah yeah
um
can you give any idea of the scale of
the comeback in terms of who you lost
and who's coming back
uh well I think it'll be very
significant
um so the advertising agencies this
point of all
um lifted their warnings on Twitter so
appreciate the fact that that group M
for example
um removed the sort of uh their concern
label over Twitter which is a very big
deal
um and so I think at this point uh
I expect almost all advertisers to
attack okay
um we've also I've done a lot more to
make the advertising uh more relevant to
users
um so that we show users things that are
they're more likely to be interested in
buying sounds obvious but right
that's what tends to happen yeah not
super obvious I mean just just basic
stuff like if you do a search on Twitter
previously this the search Banner app
um that did not take the Search terms
into account
which is pretty insane
um so just show a random ad okay whereas
obviously show an ad that is
you know matches your search sounds
sounds worth doing so just quickly
what if you've talked about the sort of
single app that does messaging and does
finance and other things I mean can you
just enlarge a little bit on sort of how
you get there and why America wants that
obviously it'll be up to people to
decide if they want it um it's like do
we make something that is useful enough
um that you want to use it more
frequently
um great that's our goal um so we're not
going to do anything to stop people
leaving the app or try to track them in
the app but let's provide enough
compiling functionality that over time
uh people's usage of the platform growth
so in 10 years time is advertising still
going to be dominant on Twitter
I think advertising will always play a
role um
at some point take 10 years from now it
may not play the largest role but it
will play the largest role for at least
a few years to come
so I want to do a quick
um quick far round of questions just you
know imagine that you're late at night
you're sitting there tweeting a few
rapid fire responses to stuff
um and I'm just going to ask you a few
questions and if you can just give me
short answers then I want to go on to AR
and talk a little bit about some of the
deeper points that you you started
making earlier
um so first one will Twitter be public
again in five years
I don't know
okay
um do you think the HQ will still be in
San Francisco
okay not good so far let's try a couple
more
um which decade are we going to crack
artificial general intelligence
I think this one this one okay so it's
that soon okay
um are you going to take a SpaceX trip
yourself
I will at some point yeah
not sure when but you'll be nice
um which is the most exciting country to
build a Tesla plant in right now
um well we did make an announcement that
Mexico would be our next uh location
outside the U.S uh and picked a site and
everything so there's that and then um
we'll probably pick another location
towards the end of this year is India
interesting
absolutely
um
are you still a fan of crypto
um well I mean I'm not advising anyone
to buy a crypto or bet the farm on you
know Dogecoin or anything like that okay
on Dogecoin might have been thinking
maybe you should but let me advise you
that would be a have some ways
um okay so it does queer is my is my
sort of favorite cryptocurrency because
uh it has the best humor and uh has dogs
um I did however look at the price of it
yesterday it's um
it's lower than it was I think
well I don't know maybe you know it's
like
friend of mine has a saying that the
most ironic explanation is the most
likely and the most ironic outcome for
currency would be that the thing that
was made at uh as a joke to make fun of
cryptocurrencies uh most ironic outcome
would become that it becomes the Global
Currency
okay we'll wait and see final one
um can you rank the US and China on
their development of AI each out of ten
um I mean the US says very much has the
uh most advanced AI so this is
you say like like China's close behind
certainly and has the resources to scale
and to optimize
um
the the biggest single advances in AI
still come from the US and Europe
but um
all right so it's hard to give an exact
number score because it's more like but
there's a big gap still
there is a there's a gap um that Gap
looks like it's on the order of
12 months right
fish
a narrowing all expanding
it's hard to tell
I
suspect it will narrow to some degree
okay
um can you talk a little bit about
you've created a new AI company
yourself
um obviously there's a huge amount of
energy and activity in this space or at
least it's been talked about I mean what
do you want to do yourself in this space
beyond Tesla and and the the stuff you
talked about earlier what is that new
thing
well I think there should be a
significant third horse in the race here
uh we've got open Ai and Microsoft
Google deepmind and probably there
should be a third horse in the race
um
so a little bit more on that soon but is
it something that will interact with the
data of Twitter and the capability of
Tesla is it something that tries to
bring what you've talked about earlier
in terms of capability together and
become that third player is that what
you're talking about
to some degree I don't want to jump a
gun here on announcements but uh
um you know the opening AI has a
relationship with Microsoft that seems
to work very well fairly well so it's
possible that
um
xai and Twitter and Tesla would have
something similar
possible
um
you've talked about the importance of
Regulation and you call for this this
moratorium I mean the history of
regulating Tech has been checkered it's
been very hard for Regulators to keep up
with tech let alone get ahead of it
what do you think actually needs to
happen that practically could in this
space to try to change that because
obviously the history of this is not
encouraging
yeah I mean I think there should be you
know I've been pushing hard for a long
time I met with a number of
um
centers and Congress people in Congress
in the white house uh to advocate for AI
regulation uh starting with an Insight
committee that is formed of independent
parties as well as perhaps participants
from the leaders in industry and that uh
that that oversight committee uh gains
um or should say get that Insight
committee gains insight into what
various companies are up to
um and uh you know to the degree that
there's
okay competitive Dynamics there you can
obviously uh you would um sequester
board members who are perhaps have
conflicts uh but anyway if you figure
out some sort of regulatory board and uh
and they start off gaining insight and
then I have proposed rulemaking
um and then that you know will get
comments that are on by industry and uh
and then hopefully we have some sort of
oversight rules that improve uh safety
just as we do with uh aircraft with the
FAA and spacecraft and cars with Nitza
and
Food and Drugs with the Food Drug
Administration
right and how would that work in such a
global thing as we're talking about
where Ai and the relative uh Advance
between countries is going to be very
very important
is that something that is is
globalizable is that is that
well really the key question is uh we'll
China uh you know cooperate with the
West
that remains to be seen
um
but I would still Advocate like some
degree of of oversight I mean we have a
regulatory oversight of aircraft
for example and yet the the US is still
very much
doing great on the aircraft
so it makes more effort than the rest
than any in any other place
so
just because you have you know FAA
regulations doesn't mean that uh it's
necessarily slowed down very much okay
um does so so your view would be that
the AI changes today lock in the tech
Giants the microsofts and the Googles of
this world does it also is there also a
scenario where it actually helps to
bring in new players and and and and and
change that dynamic or is that a much
more unlikely outcome
well
that there are um
a lot of AI startups the thing that's
becoming tricky is that in order you
really need three things
to compete you need uh Talent talented
people
um you need
um
a lot of compute expensive compute and
you need to access the data
so whoever's got whoever's succeeding on
those three will win
um
so now that the cost of compute has
gotten astronomical
so
it's now
you know
kind of sort of minimum ante I would say
uh minimum would be 250 million dollars
of silver Hardware
minimum that's like just two right
relevant in any way so the startups are
more likely to piggyback off what the
others are doing rather than
compete directly themselves is what
you're saying
yeah to train a big one um are you going
to take a SpaceX trip yourself
to train a model of probably gbt five
size
I wouldn't be surprised if they use at
least
30 30
000 maybe 50 000 h100s which are the
latest uh
gpus are not sure it's not quite the
right word but the latest
technology from Nvidia
um so and then you need to run inference
as well
um
so
there's a lot of the the G fuser
um this point considerably harder to get
than drugs
actually that's really not a high bar in
San Francisco
you can tell us more about that later
but yes okay
okay
um so
um
a couple of things I just wanted to go
into on on AI which I love your
perspective on
um is this gonna what does it mean for
society in terms of is this going to
embed wealth and power in a very small
subset and create a big widening of
inequality is it going to democratize
and create the opposite what is your
sense of of where this heads
terms of access to goods and services I
think AI will be ushering an age of
abundance assuming that we're in a
benign AI scenario
I think the AI will be able to make
goods and services
um
very inexpensively
and so
in anything that is a product or a
service where there's not artificial
scarcity created such as like I want to
live exactly in
and this you know neighborhood houses
it's like okay well there's only 100
houses there so
you know that that would still have
scarcity
um or a unique artwork would have
scarcity but anything that does not have
scarcity that we def that we
deliberately designed to be scarce will
be plentiful for everyone
in a benign scenario
and in the unbeline scenario
well there's a wide range of
but what's the thing that you're most
worried about when you look at you know
when you've been talking for years about
the need for regulation what is the
scenario that really keeps you up at
night
well I don't I don't think the AI is
going to try to destroy all Humanity but
it might
put us under strict controls
um
I mean and there's no non-zero chance of
of it going Terminator it's not zero
percent but it's it's
I think it's it's a small likelihood of
of annihilating humanity but it's not
zero we wanted at all going to be zero
close to zero as possible
and then like I said the
uh
of AI assuming control or the safety of
all the humans
and taking over all the Computing
systems and weapon systems of Earth and
effectively being like some sort of uber
nanny
but isn't isn't another scenario if you
say you say that yeah like what you know
like let's say you're uh you know I must
well contact consent contestant
hypothetically
um it's unlikely let's face it
um and and you know you say what what do
you want and so I want World Peace
um and uh it's like okay well the you
know one way to achieve well peace is to
take all the weapons away from the
humans
so they can no longer use them
and and to punish any humans that engage
in
um you know extra territorial activity
but isn't the more isn't the more likely
nasty outcome that rather than AI taking
over and being the ultimate naddy that
keeps us all
doing stuff that is super safe and it
wants us to that actually somebody
nefariously harnesses that power to
achieve societal control stroke military
superiority
um and that actually some country around
the world decides to use it in a
different way
uh yes that that's what I mean by like
AI uses as a weapon right
um and the pen is mightier than the
sword so one of the first places we have
to be careful of AI being used is in
social media to manipulate public
opinion
so the reason that uh Twitter is going
to a primarily uh subscriber based
system is because it is dramatically
harder to create it's like or 10 000
times harder uh to create a an account
that has a verified phone number from a
credible carrier that has a a credit
card and that pays a small amount of
money per month
um and have those credit cards and phone
numbers be highly distributed not
clustered
incredibly difficult
um so whereas in the past uh
someone could create a million fake
accounts for a penny a piece
and then manipulates have have something
appear to be very very much liked by the
public when in fact it is not or
promoted and retweeted when in fact it
is not is popularity is is not real
essentially gain the system so
the device towards uh a is a
subscription-based verification I think
is is very powerful and that really you
won't be able to trust any social media
company that does not do this uh because
it will simply be
overrun with Bots to such an extreme
extreme degree so if we take it back to
where we started
if you look at the election that's
coming up
how big a role will this big shift in AI
capability over the last few months
which will obviously continue through
the next year how big an impact is this
going to play do you think in the
messaging and the way that people get
told the different pictures of of the
candidates
I think that's something we need to go
and look at for in a big way is to make
sure that this we're
minimizing the impact of AI manipulation
um
we're certainly pretty much taking it
Taking that seriously at XX Twitter you
know Twitter and um
and I think we're putting in place all
of the protections to
minimize and certainly detect when we
see large-scale manipulation of the
system
okay but beyond Twitter are you worried
about this for the election in general
yeah um
there probably will be
attempts to use AI to manipulate the
public
and some of it will be successful
um
and if not the selection for sure the
next one
okay I've got two more questions on AI
if you've got the time and then just a
little bit on China and Tesla if that's
okay
um the first thing is
um we talk a lot in terms of AI about
the next five to ten years and what the
impact is going to be on jobs and some
of these things if you look out on a
much longer time frame given the speed
and scale of the change and you look to
your grandkids and great grandkids
can you just give us a sense of what
what it's going to be like to be human
how much is this going to change the
fundamental nature of how we operate as
as a race at this point
I think it's gonna change a lot
um
especially if you go further out into
the future I mean there will be
everything will
be automatic I mean they'll they'll be
household robots that you can fully talk
to as though there are people
um that can help you around the house or
be a companion or whatever the case may
be uh there will be humanoid robots
throughout you know factories
um
and um
ours will also be all automatic and
anything that that we're intelligence
can be applied
um even modest intelligence will be
automated
say like
so if you say like 10 20 years from now
and we will we be connected to that
technology through a neuralink type
Divine I mean is that is that where this
in your view obviously is that why this
heads
well
A high bandwidth interface from cortex
to the
so you're sort of computing or AI
tertiary layer which already exists uh
you know it's just that we don't have a
high bandwidth connection
um we've got a
um
limbic system which is a sort of
foundational element that's sort of our
instincts and desires and whatnot uh
they're not cortex on top of that which
is a thinking part of our brain and
about a tertiary digital layer which is
currently in the form of our phones and
computers and laptops and whatnot and
all the applications
and the the constraint on better
a better merging or
the construct you know the constraint on
on on
um having human interests and machine
interests be aligned is the bandwidth
especially the output so if you select
at what speed can you output to a
computer it's using Voice or your
fingers which will move very slowly so
you're talking about maybe 10 bits per
second or some some fairly small
data rate
um
so
with with the neural link you can
increase that by you know increase that
by a million probably
um so everything just speeds up
it's up yeah okay um I mean this is
obviously in a relatively benign
scenario because there's a question of
not just uh let's say it's a Brian
scenario
um how do we even
appreciate or understand what the
computer is doing right
um
how do we how do we go how do we go
along for the ride
um and if we have a better if you have a
brain machine interface that's
I don't know a million times faster than
or more like we'll go along for the ride
a lot better
that then if we're interfacing with a
phone using two slow-moving meat sticks
um
if you put it like that um
and in terms of you have a lot of kids
many in this room have kids
you know what do they need to what
skills do they need to have what are the
three skills that you think are most
important for them that you're trying to
give them
to be prepared and well positioned for
this new world
well I think it's it's important to have
a broad range of
of understanding in many different
subjects so I think general knowledge is
important
um
so you at least have some clue of what
you don't know in different areas and
then
go deep in areas where your child is has
a strong interest and ability
so finding that that overlap of where is
my child what interested in this and has
some ability to be successful then uh
you know Finding if you can find that
Venn diagram overlap then obviously
encouraging that is a good thing
um and we are obviously headed to a
high-tech world so some basic
understanding of computers and software
and artificial intelligence is probably
a good idea
okay
but the actual broad thrust of
um I mean jobs will change but it'll be
more AI enabling and making it better
and easier rather than wholesale
complete change of the skills you need
Which principle what time frame we're
talking about here so
if you say like over
20 30 year time frame
I think things will be transformed
beyond belief
what you probably think you probably
won't recognize Society in 30 years
um
like I do think we're fairly close you
asked me about artificial general
intelligence I think we're perhaps only
three years maybe six years away from it
this this decade
um
so
the impact arguably we are on the Event
Horizon
of the black hole that is
social super intelligence
okay
so I'm going to ask one final question
I'm going to see if you've got two
minutes to take a couple of questions
from the floor and it's it comes back to
China which you talked about a little
bit you have a very big business in
China in Tesla
um and obviously you know you're on that
geopolitical fault line that's getting
um potentially interesting it to what
extent is this affecting your decision
making around sort of how you put assets
and and stuff on the ground and how
concerned are you about that as a
business person and a lot of people in
this room have business in China about
that getting very very difficult for us
well there is fundamentally
um
an issue that's coming to a head with
Taiwan
um
and it's unclear when exactly Bush will
come to show but it seems that
there's a good chance push will come to
shove it's trending in that direction
um
I'd rather think what what that would
happen
the results would be for the global
economy would be absolutely catastrophic
um
but um you know China has been very
clear about its goal on China and uh
sort of um
including Taiwan
um as part of China so
one does not need to read between the
lines one can simply read the lines
they were bracelet
and they're not getting
and is the biggest concern despite you
know the the the the prospect of
conflict itself
um obviously a lot of the world's
high-end chips
come out of Taiwan I mean how
catastrophic would that be if that was
cut off
well there's even more that comes out of
China so
the transit is a lot so much of of the
world's heavy lifting on manufacturing
especially if the manufacturing is
you know simply hard work and say not
not particularly glamorous
um
charges does an immense amount of hard
work that people most people have no
idea how much hard work they do so
um
you kind of from
Taiwan was much less less of a concern
than being covered from time from China
now China would reciprocally suffer of
course
um because I would say that the economy
of
the economies of
China and Taiwan are they're like
conjoined twins with the what
the Western economy with the rest of the
world
so China China the West the rest of the
world being Conjuring twins from an
economic standpoint will mean that the
separation is going to be
dire indeed
okay
that happens I hope it does not happen
so
um
and there's no easy solution here
but if there's any if there's any path
to diplomatic solution we should really
take that seriously great do you have
time to take a few questions from the
floor Elon
sure does anybody have a question they'd
like to pose we'll go here and then here
Mike behind you
thanks Elon thanks for joining us
um I'm the founder of a real estate
business in Newcastle in the northeast
of England
um
we export manufacture and Export more
cars from the Northeast than the whole
of Italy uh
would you let me build you a
Tesla Factory in the northeast of
England
thanks for the offer so
probably consider uh England uh for a
future location of a geiger Factory
thank you I'll get you so you will you
will consider it
are you actively considering it
uh we we we we're not currently uh
looking at new locations but we will
pull towards the end of this year
I'll send you some plans okay
um uh David here please
thank you for your time uh Fusion
lots of scientists say it could change
the world Planet it's the sun all live
on this planet and on Mars depends on
Fusion the sun itself can I ask you why
a man of your brilliant brain resources
and talent
it's not actually focusing on Fusion
which I think could be a game changer
for society and rather than on Twitter
where there are many media decent
companies that can do it and I would say
it almost in a trivial way
well I'm I think we already have a giant
Fusion reactor in the sky that called
the Sun that shows up every day so
um which always said like if you want to
know what's standing in front of a
future Fusion reactor feels like just go
out go and stand in front of the sun you
know just walk outside
that's what that's what a giant Fusion
reactor feels like because that's what
the sun is
um it converts about four and a half
million towns four and a half million
tons of Mass to energy every second
and requires no maintenance
it's amazing
um you don't have to you don't have to
refuel it you don't have to maintain it
just there so
my recommendation for Fusion is solar
power and batteries and we can easily
power all of Earth with uh just with
photovoltaics and batteries not I mean
not easily but there's just a very clear
path to do so
um
and and uh no Miracles are quiet just
work interesting I've also an advocate
of wind and of of nuclear fission
uh geothermal hydro and whatnot
uh we'll take a couple more one here and
then the lady at the back
thank you as you're considering exposure
to China and particularly
um in the EV space and with the battery
supply chain what's your process for
evaluating political risk in the near
and Midterm
I guess I just talked to my team
you know read the news
uh
I don't know
assess assess the opinion on Twitter I
suppose
um
there's a very deep analysis you can get
on Twitter from people that are World
experts on a particular subject so
um
I don't know I think we just we try to
prepare for the worst hope for the best
um
and um
you know make sure we have factories and
uh geographically Diversified regions of
the world where the supply chain is as
localized as possible
but this is important uh also for forced
Azure situations so if there are
earthquakes wildfires riots revolutions
uh ice storms uh heat waves
uh you name it uh I think I've seen it
all at this point so you want to have
you you want to have a supply chain that
does not inherit Force Major from all of
Earth
um
because something that's going to happen
somewhere it's Big Planet so so that's
why I think it's important to have um
localized Supply chains with factories
in in many geographies
uh last question from the lady at the
back thank you yeah you famously tweeted
that you thought the population collapse
was a much bigger risk to humanity than
climate change
what do you think States
families even companies can do to ensure
that more of us want to have more
children
well yeah I mean I think it's it's very
telling if you look at the birth rates
which are just you know publicly
available
um you can look at uh say the birth rate
last year for every country
um it's available online
um and you can look at the trend in both
rates and it's just very clear that the
trend has been strongly downward
um and that we've recently hit all-time
lows so
um you think if you know during covert
you know what else you got to do you
might as well have a kid but
um it didn't happen actually we had a
big drop in birth rate during during
covert
an increase in divorces too since
make a lot of time with their
significant other
um so
I think generally
um
so it's simply changing people's mind
about the goodness of having kids it's
like very important to have kids in
order to to continue civilization
um and I think sometimes it's viewed as
uh you know kids are viewed as an
imposition on the world I don't think
that's the case at all or that people
sometimes think there are too many
people in the world that's that's
certainly not the case you can you can
fit all of the humans on Earth on one
floor in the city of New York
you know it would be uncomfortable but
but just to give you a sense of the
cross-sectional area of earth that is
human is very tiny it just seems big if
you're in a big city
um but for the vast majority of the
earth if if you're given a task of
from front plane of dropping a bowling
ball and and and you have to hit someone
you'd you'd Miss I almost never hit
anyone
um so
uh what is that you very rarely go over
a person
um
in an aircraft you fly from LA to New
York the vast areas of land with no one
at all so anyway the
I think we want to just generally have
it be socially
encouraged to have kids I think
certainly companies need to support uh
employees that have kids
um I think in terms of government
incentives uh there should be
uh some I think tax breaks for having
kids you know or make it just
financially not burdensome to have
children
um
and it's always worth bearing in mind
like
autonomy aside
um if someone doesn't have kids what
you're actually asking is that uh
someone else's kids take care of you
when you're old
and that that doesn't seem like quite
right you know
um
because because that's that's the world
before they'll be forced to do absent
automation is is that someone else the
kids will have to take care of you when
you're old and
um
you know so I think
anyway one way or another we need to
solve this birth rate issue or
civilization will go a little to nothing
isn't that where AI comes in it'll do
all the jobs for us so we can we can
handle a
uh
potentially lower population or what
you're talking about
I think there will be robot nannies that
are very confident
so that will help